herzlich willkommen zu sein bedeutet mir
geht sowie sicherlich einigen von euch
auch in den letzten tagen dieser
quarantänezeit schaue ich mir den ganzen
tag irgendwie so deutsche - compilations
auf youtube anfangs schön öfters spies
was du so schön es gibt ein deutsches
team das hier mit sicherheit kennt was
einfach bei mir hängen geblieben ist
das ist einfach das hat so das hat
irgendwas besonderes dieses minister
dass marshall einfach die hübsche mir
und ich musste schon wieder dieses
denken dass ich mir das passt eigentlich
perfekt weil ich ja auch schon die
andere die strengsten eltern der welt
reaction gemacht habe und dieses mini
maus die strengsten eltern der welt
kommt deswegen schauen wir uns heute
einfach mal die strengsten eltern der
welt folge von dieser marke an diesen
legendären satz geprägt hat und ja denn
jetzt los
vor der ankunft der beiden teenies
möchte übersetzer daniel der gastfamilie
zeigen mit wem sie es in den nächsten
zwei wochen zu tun haben werden
dass wir nochmals kontext also fast
nicht wusste bei die strengsten eltern
der welt werden kinder halt irgendwo ans
andere ende der welt geschickt in
irgendwelche entwicklungsländern wo halt
die kein fließendes wasser haben wir das
ist weiß auch nicht warum genau dahin
ist aber so
und wer dann halt darüber wird dann
wieder auf den richtigen weg kommen dass
man die erzielt aber leute entwickeln
die beschreibung gibt uns auch schon
aufschluss darüber was für ein mensch
diese mata von mascha einfach die
hübsche so ist die betreiber lautet
nämlich marta hat am pro einen abszess
in deutschland war sie zu vorher zum
arzt zu gehen
jetzt kommt die retourkutsche dafür
der erste eindruck shop die gastfamilie
es sieht also konzentriert wird aber da
muss alles wirklich diese dieser look
hat mich auch traumatisiert dieser look
hier leute ich weiß nicht was das ist
also das hat mich wirklich traumatisiert
so sein
zu meiner schulzeit so erste also fünfte
sechste klasse gymnasium die ganze
massive aussieht seht ihr heute auch
noch so aus ich gehe nicht mehr die
schule ich weiß es nicht mehr länger
dass sie das sieht aus wie das sieht aus
wie ein stinktier diese frisur so krass
wenn ihr sie seht leute denken nicht
über das nach was jetzt hier von ihr
seht wenn ihr sie seht sagt einfach
mascher life hat die hübsche sagt nichts
anderes auf ihrer reise nach madagaskar
zeigen martha und fabian die üblichen
verhaltensmuster die verwöhnte
17-jährige gibt der fluggesellschaft die
schultern den schmerzen an ihrem gesäß
richtig so leute wenn sie einen abszess
also eine entzündung an ihrem hintern
hat ja und damit nicht in deutschland
zum arzt geht ist es selbstverständlich
die schulter fluggesellschaft dass sie
dann schmerzen hat also ich finde
fluggesellschaften müssen damit rechnen
dass leute mit fetten abszessen da
hinkommt madame luxus ist sich sicher
und sie hat einen anspruch auf einen
sitz in der ersten klasse
versteht man nicht der läuft läuft etwas
schief bei dieser fluggesellschaften ja
also es ist symptomatisch natürlich für
die strengsten eltern der welt dass die
kinder die da sind einfach überall
verkackt also wollen dann auch noch
erster klasse fliegen weil sie zu dumm
sind mit pickel zum arzt zu gehen
das ist geil
so eine einstellung muss man auch
erstmal irgendwie erreichen im leben was
eine ernst zu nehmende entzündung wie
schmerzhaft ist wenn du sitzt geht aber
nicht zum arzt was hast du gedacht was
passiert und wie war die reise martha
macht das was sie am besten kann ich
habe an der japaner vorher kommt ins
fernsehen ist also ihr erster
fernsehauftritt und was von euch hängen
bleibt ist das hier einfach hinten bis
es am arbeitet und zudem wartet mit
diesem absatz zum arzt zu gehen und mal
so einfach komplett abschluss wirklich
wie kann man so sein wie kann man auch
so sein als frau thema vor jungs ihr
seid auch so ein date mit seinem zum
girl und denn irgendein typ trampelt die
an und sie doch mal machst
ich konnte ich konnte nicht aushalten oh
mein gott was für eine entscheidung muss
man sie aber ganz bestimmt auch nicht
daran
ok also wir müssen es nach wie vor für
alle halten was ist für alle die nicht
wissen was ein abszess das absetzen von
eine größere entzündung wenn es war für
mich als medizinischen laien so
dargestellt und das ist natürlich krank
schmerzhaft so das tut schon böse werden
das ist denke ich mal dein auto fährst
aber das gute ist dass dann quasi so ein
schlagloch ein melder hinten im auto
weil egal bei der kleinsten unebenheiten
der straße komponenten immer ein abo
fabian und martha wissen immer noch
nicht wo sie die nächsten zwei wochen
leben werden
sie wird glaube ich gleich dazu
übergehen erst mal ihren eigenen
absetzen bombe zuzugeben dass der aspekt
der du bist an der hübschen jetzt gerade
daran okay oder
das fällt ja er hat nicht mal gesagt
auf jeden fall ist ja ist einfach ein
marta ist einfach ein besonderer mensch
muss man auch das so sagen leute sie
läuft als käse weißer mensch durch
madagaskar war der gast kann liegt wie
gesagt vor der küste von afrika der
großteil der menschen daten dunklen haut
und als weißer mensch mit der hand ab
und alle zwei sekunden vor schmerzen
stehen läuft die kranken und die leute
schauen sie einfach an und sagen nicht
die bahn zieht x20 aus und und dadurch
sollte oder zerrissen und einfach geil
wir können wie kommt man auf dieser
stufe der existenz an leute wie kommt
man dahin will sie ist in madagaskar im
krankenhaus und sagt dass es aussieht
wie ein keller weil das land ist nicht
richtig gestrichen und das ist alles
kaputt
es ist egal wie die sich das einfach
zwei dieses wesen ist einfach 2000 das
geht überhaupt nicht das was wir für
diesen kleinen einblick in die person
hinter das minimiert die kritiker und
natürlich vorschlagen könne makabren wer
euch verbunden werden so nett wäre
einmal für die hübsche zu beten dass das
mit dem absatz wieder gut geht genau an
der stelle noch aus